on va prendre la direction de la
bretagne plus précisément caudan ou la
fonderie et proposés à la vente par le
groupe renoue décision que les élus
bretons condamne dans une période de
crise sanitaire ou l'emploi souffre on
vient dessus avec notre reporter bassin
chebbi il est accompagné de renaud
parquet pour les images nouvelles
journées de grèves ici à l'appel de la
cgt à la fonderie de bretagne à caudan
dans le morbihan les ouvriers sont bien
décidés à bloquer le site jusqu'à ce que
la direction puisse répondre à leurs
questions et leur donner des réponses
concernant cette annonce faite par le
groupe renault de vouloir se séparer du
site
ici c'est l'incompréhension pour les
ouvriers alors que l'usiné rentable et
tourne à plein régime
je vous propose d'écouter certains de
ses ouvriers on attend des réponses
mains des politiciens la direction de
direction des technos ans qui sort donc
de on veut savoir où l'on voit parce que
là on n'a rien on sait rien du tout
renault je pense que ce qu'ils ont
derrière la tête c'est de faire c'est de
faire comme comme tous les grands
groupes en fait c'est de faire au moins
cher en fait et comme on sait que les
pays les pays européens comme l'espagne
la turquie le portugal hills ils sont
aussi capables déjà de faire nos pièces
en double parce que renault le l'idée
qu'ils ont ces deux ressources et leurs
cris c'est à dire qu'ils font des copies
de pièces partout dans l'europe donc le
jour où une usine française ils en ont
plus besoin
ils sont capables de les délocaliser en
espagne au brésil au portugal on entende
parler de deux noms d'entreprises mais
en fait c'est les entreprises bas qu'on
entend parler autour de nous mais en
fait des repreneurs qui serait pas qui
serait pas viable en fait qu'ils vont
rester peut-être là une année ou deux
qui va comme on a connu il ya quelques
années en fait qui font qu'ils vont nous
servir de notre fonderie pleine balle en
fête et puis qui vont pas investir et
puis elle va se dégrader et puis on sera
on reviendra au point de départ en fait
où il faudra encore se battre pour aller
chercher un groupe qui a de l'argent et
qu'ils réinvestissent de nouveau en vrai
on est là justement pour qu'on se bat
pour montrer que l'entreprise a un
avenir et ce qu'on attend c'est des
réponses de la direction des réponses
claires et précises qui veulent pas nous
donner
on sait que ils ont des réponses mais le
pas le dévoiler mais on est là justement
pour montrer que l'entreprise et dia
avec ça peut pas durer longtemps
cela fait plus d'un an que les ouvriers
de cette fonderie se bat pour sauver
leur emploi c'est l'incompréhension
totale ici d'autant que le groupe
renault a bénéficié de cinq milliards
d'euros dans le cadre d'un plan de
relance pour sortir de l'impasse pour le
moment les ouvriers on déclarait
continuer le combat continue à faire ce
genre de mouvements notamment des
blocages de la fonderie temps qu'une
discussion n'aura pas été instaurée
entre les ouvriers et la direction
ces mêmes juillet qui espère pouvoir
être reçu à paris par le ministère de
l'économie